hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
optimizing transfection to generate
high tighter aav and lentiviral
vectors this webinar is part of the bio
processing
virtual event i'm susie valdez of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and mirror us for more
information about mirrors go to
nearestbio.com so let's get started
before we begin i want to remind
everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting
as many questions as you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
simply click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of the screen as a reminder this
presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education
credits click on the continuing
education credits tab
located at the top right corner of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits i now present
today's speaker dr sandy singh
a technical support scientist for
complete biography of our speaker please
visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen sandy welcome
to you
you may now begin your presentation
hello thanks for coming to this webinar
my name is sandy
i am a technical support scientist at
muris bio
and today i'll be discussing ways to
improve aav
and lentivirus production through
optimization of transfection
first i want to give a little background
on mira's bio for those of you who
aren't familiar with us
i also want to touch on how these viral
vectors
aav lentivirus how they're being used
for cell and gene therapies
then i'll focus on how it mirrors we've
examined ways to maximize
on aev and lentiviral titers through
optimizing parameters
that surround transfection and i'll be
touching on these
parameters here one after the other and
i'll end the q
a if you're watching this live
meera's bio was established in 1995 from
the research of scientists
at the university of wisconsin-madison
at the time they were exploring the
cutting edge of gene delivery and
they came at it from a very
interdisciplinary approach that involved
chemistry
physics cell molecular biology and since
then
mears has been known as the transfection
experts
here's a picture of some of us in 2019
that's me over here
to this day we're still headquartered in
beautiful madison wisconsin usa
however our reach is international and
we offer distribution and support for
scientists around the world here
i just want to highlight a few
milestones in mirror's history
and how we've evolved over the years to
meet the needs of the scientific
community
our first transfection region that is
still a big hit today is transit lt1
it was the first to be compatible with
transfection of cells that were still
growing in serum containing media and it
did so with high efficiency and low
toxicity
hence lt for low toxicity and
not a transfection region per se but we
developed a chemistry
label it for tracking transfection
through labeling of
nucleic acids with tags such as
fluorophores
and it did so without impeding gene
expression
of the nucleic acid we also developed
reagents specifically
for high efficiency delivery of small
oligos such as sirna
as well as larger rna like mrna with our
transit mrna kit
and we've also developed products for
electroporation of cells
that are difficult to transfect with
chemical reagents
and transit 2020 and x2 are really next
generation transfection reagents
they were designed to transfect cell
types that were previously
untransfectable with chemical
transfection reagents
um transit x2 can also deliver
cas9 ribonuclear protein complexes
and to support protein production in
suspension
cells such as cho and 293 we introduce
transit pro and our chogro family of
products
now and the topic of this talk today is
our recent developments with reagents
for virus production
scientists have been using our transit
regions for virus production for decades
but we noticed an increasing demand for
virus in light of advances in gene and
cell therapies
coming to market so to address this
mirrors has developed
virus gen transfection reagents
all right so before jumping into the
main part of my talk about optimizing
transfection for virus production
i just want to highlight what i mean by
advances in gene and cell therapies
that use virus so viruses get a bad rap
these days
and obviously there's a good reason for
that but
a non-pathogenic recombinant virus can
be produced to
house therapies for delivery using that
same
infectious potential so what's the
difference between
gene and cell therapies well what it
comes down to
is what form the therapeutic takes so in
gene therapy
the packaged gene is therapeutic while
in cell therapy
the engineered cells are therapeutic and
because the gene
is the therapy and gene therapy the
virus containing the packaged gene is
directly introduced to patients
such as in the administration of aav
in cell therapies the viral vector
is introduced to cells that have been
removed from the patient
ex vivo the cells are then reintroduced
into the patient
and engineering of patient cells is
often performed with
lentivirus or lentiviral vectors
so really right about the time mirus was
founded the first gene therapy was
licensed by the fda
and subsequently discontinued that's
what those
pink colored boxes indicate and not for
safety reasons
in either case in the case of vitravine
the disease
that it treated was being stamped out in
other ways
anyhow this review from 2020 summarizes
the
22 gene and cell therapies that have
been approved for use around the world
which might not seem like a lot but what
is significant is
the growth um since the 90s accelerating
to today
for glibera this was known as the 1
million
drug because it literally cost 1 million
usd per patient which is obviously quite
costly
and it was discontinued because it was
costly relative to its utilization
and globera is was an aav based gene
therapy
and virus-based therapies as you can see
here in this pie chart
make up a significant portion of the 22
approved
gene and cell therapies
we are likely going to see an increase
in the number of approved
gene and cell therapies as evidence of
this
as of 2021 when this industry report was
released
1220 active clinical trials
involving cell and gene therapies are
ongoing
in these various phases
and this chart here shows a number of
new clinical studies posted each year
since 2000
which mentioned the use of aav and
lentivirus
specifically and as you can see it's
clearly growing
in order to support these therapies that
means
a high quantity or high titer of
virus will be required and it's
estimated
that the dosage is around the order of
10 to the power of 8
or the power of 10 in the case of cell
therapies
and to remind you patient cells are
transduced ex vivo
and once edited the cells can then be
further propagated
the average dose for aav based gene
therapies
is larger it's around the order of 10 to
the power of 11
up to 16 depending on where and how much
virus will be required for
the treatment and it's much higher
because the vector is administered
directly to the patient
for transduction of affected tissues and
the virus may have to contend with
clearance from the body
so it goes without saying to maximize
production of these vectors
is desirable to support these therapies
and make them
affordable at scale and the transfection
step of aav
and lentivirus manufacture is a critical
point to achieve this
so to remind you aav and lentivirus is
often produced
through transient transfection of 293
cells which is step one here
in these diagrams and the aav and
lentivirus is
collected post-transfection and is
further processed
okay so on to the meat of the talk which
is to discuss the ways we can improve
yield of aav and lentivirus through
optimizing this critical step in
production transfection
uh so before we get to the q a we will
discuss
these parameters okay
so first the reagent transit virus gen
reagent was developed by mirus
with this workflow in mind we first
screened our vast library of molecules
and compounds to identify
regions that would result in the highest
yields of aav and lentivirus
we used a reporter gfp system where the
aav2 or lentivirus contained
a gfp transgene secondly
we also wanted to ensure that our
reagent would be compatible for both
suspension
and adherent hec293 cells in either
serum containing or serum free
conditions
and another important parameter was that
the protocol for use of our reagent
would be robust
and scalable because we know how
important
consistency is to any process in
addition to getting a really great
titer
and so a couple of years ago in about
2017
we introduced our transit virus gen
reagent which accomplished
all of that and specifically to address
the needs of
our pre-clinical and commercial
manufacturing customers we launched our
select
format of the reagent this is going to
be closely followed by the launch this
year
of a completely gmp manufactured version
what's important to note is that all of
these formats
ruo select and gmp are identical in
formulation
so any development work done with the
transit virus gen
ruo regent can be applied seamlessly to
the use of the select and gmp transit
virus gen
reagent and together with the launch of
the gmp reagent will be the launch of
our virus
gen aav transfection kit and virus gen
lentivirus transfection kit or lv
transfection kit
these kits include enhancer solutions
which
further boost virus production these
kits will also be available
in ruo select and gmp formats
later this year okay
so we benchmarked our reagents against
other commonly used transfection
reagents that are pei based
so what i'm showing you here are
functional titers
for aav on the left and lentivirus on
the right
in suspension 293 culture and as you can
see the addition
of the enhancer component of the virus
gen kit
greatly improves the yield of aav
compared to competing reagents
and the same case for lentivirus
so which reagent that you use obviously
has a very
significant impact on vector yields but
so can
optimizing the cell culture conditions
of your 293 culture
in this experiment here we examine cell
density at the time of transfection for
xp293 cells
used for the production of aav and
we looked at using either the reagent
alone
or in the presence of the enhancer
component
shown here in red so as you can see the
cell density at the time of transfection
clearly impacts the resultant titers
especially for
when the enhancer component of the
viruschen aav kit is used
and for this particular system we would
recommend a cell density at transfection
of about three to four million cells per
mill
optimizing cell density also applies for
lentivirus production
and in this experiment um lentivirus
titers were highest
when cells were at 4 million cells
per ml at the time of transfection
shown here is data for an optimization
experiment that we performed for
adherent cells
they were t17s grown in serum containing
dmm
what's shown on the x-axis is the
feeding density
the day before and the images below show
the percent confluency at time of
transfection
again the titers are shown for the minus
and plus
enhancer component and in each case the
enhancer boosts titers
generally we do not recommend that cells
are over confluent
or covering the entire plate at the time
of transfection
also we don't recommend that they're at
a low density
as yields tend to be lower when there
are less cells or
when cell health decreases because of
being over confluent
so as you can see here it appears that
even if cells were accidentally seeded
too high
use of the enhancer could counteract
those negative effects on yield
all right moving on from cell culture
which i just touched the tip of the
iceberg on
using a shake flask or a bioreactor
different cell line different media type
etc
these are all unique features of your
cell culture system
that can be considered when you're
optimizing transfection
but dna is just as important and unique
so
not only the dna quality but the amount
of dna that's used
as well as the packaging and transfer
plasmids that are used during
transfection
so shown here in this experiment where
we used virus gen lv kit
with the enhancer with 500 000
cells per ml seeded the day before we
tested uh
two dna systems with different amounts
of dna
per transfection we maintain the same
ratio of region at three to one
micrograms of dna i should say three
microliters per one microgram of dna
and notice here on the y-axis there is
an almost
10-fold increase in lentivirus titer
when the p-alt system from aldeveron
was used and the optimal mass of dna to
use per transfection
also varied this really highlights
that the dna that you use is an
important consideration
for transfection optimization not only
for
each unique cell culture system but also
for each unique
vector that's being produced
in this experiment i'm highlighting the
effect of the
ratio of reagent to dna so microliters
of reagent two micrograms of dna
as well as the amount of dna that's used
in the transfection
so these were aav production experiments
performed
in suspension 293 cells with the
enhancer in the virus gen aav kit
in this experiment we looked at two
ratios two to one or three to one
and a one to two microgram of dna
transfected per
milliliter of culture and as you can see
the two to one ratio is clearly better
for aav tighter than the three to one
regardless of the amount of dna that was
used
for this particular experimental system
and aav vector
2 to 1 at 1.5 or 2 micrograms
produced the highest titers so when
you're considering doing an
optimization experiment like this you
could test different ratios
like 1.5 to 1 for example with a dna
titration
and gmp manufactured dna it can be an
expensive resource
so optimizing dna amounts used is
definitely
also important for this reason
next another interesting parameter to
consider which
may not be on your radar is complex
formation conditions
and by complex formation i mean the
process of mixing
dna with transfection reagent the
resultant dna reagent complex is what is
added to cells
and so in this aav production experiment
we examined the temperature of complex
formation
as well as the time we allowed complexes
to form before we added them to cells
as you can see uh high aav titers can be
obtained
from complexes that were formed at
either four degrees
or room temperature at four degrees we
think complexes grow a bit slower
for this experimental system and vector
we'd recommend
an incubation time of about 30 minutes
and i also just want to make two notes
that are applicable to
all culture systems and transfection
with transit virus gen
and the first is that the transit virus
generation should not
sit in the complex formulation solution
by itself
for long periods of time so we recommend
generally that
the dna component is added first
followed by the reagent
if the reagent is added first the dna
should follow within five minutes
and the second point that i want to
make is that you do want to mix
well after each addition so after you
add dna mix well after you
add reagent mix well but afterwards we
don't recommend
additional mixing as additional
agitation can disrupt
the complex formation and form complexes
which may have a negative effect on
titers
and here is a similar complex formation
time course experiment we performed
for aav production using the virus gen
aav
kit with and without enhancer and
same idea here about 30 minutes was
optimal for yields for this experimental
system
playing around with other complex
formation conditions can
improve titers and importantly it should
be considered for
different culture and vector systems in
order to achieve
the highest titer
the last topic i wanted to touch on is
the last stage of transfection
not quite transfection itself but uh the
assessing
of viral vector titer and what i'm
showing you here
is a comparison of transfection for
lentivirus production
using the transit virus gen reagent
alone
or pei in adherent 293 t17
cells and this is data courtesy of dr
drobna
who produced lentivirus that had an rfp
reporter
one of the vectors contained a control
rfp
in the a panels and another vector
containing
a cas9 rfp fusion and the b
panels and these images show
rfp transgene expression most likely off
the transfer plasmid that was used
during transfection
and not from the lentivirus that was
being produced and secreted into the
supernatant
these images were captured 17 to 22
hours post transfection
looks great that the transfection of the
plasmids worked
and virusgen is kicking butt over pei
but transfection efficiency of the
plasmids used to produce virus it is
important
however i want to caution that using
transfection
efficiency is no substitute for titer
i think the data from this experiment
i'm going to share in the next few
slides really demonstrate that point
we transfected xp293 cells using the
virus gen aav kit with the enhancer
component
we also included a negative
untransfected condition
meaning no reagents or dna were added to
cells
and what we did was we transfected cells
with plasmas that are required for aav
production
so in one case we transfected all three
of them
um that's the transfer plasmid that
encodes the
gfp gene the rep cap plasmid
and the plasmid p helper which contains
genes required for high titer aav
production
and in another transfection we didn't
include p helper so in place of p helper
we used a
non-coding filler plasmid and
when we evaluated transfection
efficiency
using gfp transgene expression you can
see that there are comparable
gfp positive cells that's what the bars
represent
the dots represent gfp intensity even
in the transfection where no p helper
plasmid was
included so now
i'm showing you the aav titer
and you probably know where this is
going when we properly titered
the aav produced using a functional
assay
you see that there is actually no virus
detected when
no p helper was included in the
transfection so if you were to just look
at transfection efficiency or transgene
expression post transfection
you might incorrectly assume
that there was an equivalent level of
virus being produced between these two
transfections
and so just briefly how we
did this functional titer was that we
collected the sample after transfection
and we took that aav sample and
transduced
or infected ht1080 cells with a limiting
dilution of the virus
and from the number of ht1080 cells that
express the gfp
we then were able to determine a
functional titer
i hope this experiment and the data here
really
makes the point clear that transfection
efficiency should not be substituted for
proper titering of virus
so what methods are there to properly
titer or quantify how much virus is in a
sample
and there are many methods each with
their pros and cons
you can check out this reference card
from the mirror's website
and today i'm going to focus on these
two
in an example we talked about functional
titering being a measure
of how infectious or capable the
collected virus is
at transducing a target cell in the
context of therapies that would be
how therapeutic is that virus sample
and another category of titering is
known as physical tittering
meaning not directly quantifying
infectious potential
but rather a physical attribute of the
virus and this could be something like
protein quantity of aav capsid or
lentivirus surface protein
or the amount of genetic material
dna or rna packaged in the virus sample
here's an example of functional and
physical titers plotted side by side
for this experiment we produced aav
using the virus gen aav
kit without or with the enhancer
component
and we also transfected cells with these
other commercially available reagents
the left graph here shows the functional
titer
that was done using that same ht 1080
infectious assay that i mentioned
earlier
and on the right are physical titers
that were collected using a dd-pcr-based
assay
to measure genome copies as you can see
there are some differences though the
general trends in tighter track
between the two and um
we also looked at harvesting aav at 72
hours
versus 48 hours post-transfection so
these are titers for the harvest at 72
hours
here side by side i'm highlighting the
aav titers for the sample collected at
an earlier time point the 48 hour
post transfection and as you can see
highest tiders are achieved with the
virus gen with the enhancer component
that is the whole virus gen aav kit
at an earlier time point at least for
this stereotype culture system
and transfection conditions and this is
clearly reflected for
the functional titer and so based on
this assessment
for this system we would recommend a
harvest time of 48
rather than 72 hours post-transfection
all right so you probably heard me
repeat the phrase several times today
for this particular system
vector and transfection conditions so
transfection is pretty straightforward
and the general protocol is the same
you add dna you add reagent to your
cells
but to really eek out ever higher
amounts of virus
you might want to consider optimizing
transfection on
a case-by-case basis by examining some
of the parameters that i pointed out
today and the protocols that are
provided by manufacturers are great
starting points
so at miras we are more than happy to
work with you to discuss
your unique workflows and systems and
requirements for transfection
so to summarize here are some potential
variables you could consider
for an optimization study obviously one
of the
important outputs in such a study would
be the viral titer with the goal being
to achieve maximal functional and
physical titer
a true study of a matrix of all these
variables
is a huge undertaking and here are some
of the variables
that i mentioned today
so going back to this image to remind
you why
you would even want to eke out more and
more virus
through transfection optimization
clearly quite a lot of virus
needs to be produced in order to support
gene and cell therapies today
and in the future so we can estimate
the amount of virus that is going to be
required per dose
so treatments whether they're
administered locally or systemic
will require a lot of virus and if we
take
yield as these ballpark estimates here
you can see that the virus required per
dose
gets to be quite high in the hundreds to
thousands of liter
range in the case of a systemic
treatment
and if you can achieve the same amount
of virus with
less cell culture and number of
transfections
this would be extremely helpful not only
for
material costs but also labor and
workflow costs
and especially precious time
so some concluding remarks here high
viral titers
are required for these exciting
therapies
and hopefully we're going to see more
and more of these therapies doing
amazing things in the years to come and
while transfection
is just one aspect of advancing these
therapies
i hope i've convinced you that
optimization of transfection is a
worthwhile endeavor to produce
the highest tider a virus in order to
support these gene and cell therapies
and lastly we are happy that our transit
virus and reagent alone
or together with the enhancer solutions
in the virus gen
aav and lv transfection kits can help in
this journey to
produce high tiders of aav and
lentiviral vectors
for these exciting therapies
if you are interested in testing the
transit virus gen reagent
and or the virus gen aav or lv kits
don't hesitate to reach out to either
myself directly or through tech support
by email or phone
as i mentioned earlier mirror scientists
are happy to
discuss your unique transfection
workflows
and with that i'll call it here and take
any questions
thank you so much sandy for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have
any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
so let's get started it looks like
sandy we already have some great
questions coming in from our audience
members
our first question why are the ratios
you start with
are or what what they are you use
one to one but then recommend one to 1.5
can you tell us a little more about that
uh yeah sure happy to explain that so
i'm not quite sure where you saw the one
to
one
but i think you're talking about the
microliter of reagent to dna ratio
and this is going to vary by what
experimental system you're using and
packaging next things like that
but essentially the the general range
that we came up with for our protocols
is based on the amount of reagent
that you can think of as a concentration
that is provided
and so um actually the ratio that we'd
recommend
working with first is closer to the
range of two to one
to three to one um and
anything that is dramatically different
from this like maybe
something crazy like 10 to 1 would
cause the complexes to form a little bit
too quickly something that's
dramatically smaller than this let's say
like .25 to one
would have the reverse problem so you
can definitely get away
with differing in the ratio there
but i would stick to the general
range of one to one to about maybe even
five to one
yes i hope that was your question if you
want to clarify more you can
feel free to add another question thank
you so much danny
now what is your complex formation
volume relative
to your total culture volume
yeah so i don't i didn't think i talked
about that but that is definitely
something
that can be optimized as well so to
repeat that's a complex formation volume
that's essentially the volume of the
solution that you use
that you use to form your complexes
where you add your dna
and the reagent to and in our protocols
it's generally around 10 percent
of the total culture volume so if your
culture volume
is 25 milliliters 10 of that would be
2.5
milliliters and we've done some
experiments where we
drop that down to five percent rather
than
10 percent and what we find is the
complex
size grows a bit quicker so if you do
want to play around
with your complex formation volume you
might also want to think about
how long you're allowing those complexes
to form
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience members for these
great questions
coming in our next question
our validation process requires that we
evaluate
multiple lots of reagent
is this something you would support
sandy
um yeah so that would depend on
so we have different formats of our
reagents they're the same formulation
but we have an ruo select and gmp
manufactured version and for the ruo
and select version we already have
several different lots available
so you can evaluate the different lots
of those the gmp
reagent which is going to be released
later this year about end of may
beginning of june
there is just one initial lot however
following the initial release i think in
a few months following we'll have an
additional two batches
so depending on which
format you want to evaluate yes there
will be multiple lots
to to test thank you so much we have
time for one more question
can you explain your process for
functionally
tightering virus yeah sure so
i kind of went over that in the
presentation already i mentioned that
for
the aav2 that we've been producing
the most in-house here at muras we've
been using ht 1080 cells
and a functional titering method
essentially is
trying to measure how much of the sample
can infect
a target cell so for the aav2
because ht1080s can be infected by them
we use hd1080s and what you do is you
can
count how many ht1080s are in a given
well you can apply
your virus directly to the well and what
you're trying to measure is
how much of those cells was infected
and those are called transduction units
and the the way that you can count
the number of cells that were infected
um what we do is a flow based or flow
cytometry based assay
um so if there's a gfp reporter gene in
uh packaged in your aav for instance or
lentivirus
you can count how many of those cells
are gfp positive using flow cytometry
and from there
you can relate that to
the number of viral particles that were
in your sample that are functional
and since you know the volume that you
applied to the well
you can get a concentration transduction
units per
milliliter of sample so you can
design your assay based on what's
packaged in your virus
so if you don't have a reporter gene
instead if you want to use flow
cytometry you can use an antibody that
finds your protein or gene that's being
expressed in your
in your virus thank you so much danny we
actually have time for one more
i saw another one come in how do you
plan to use this study in the world
like what do you hope to accomplish yeah
sure that's a
more um i guess a more abstract kind of
question but
i think it's easily answerable by the
kinds of
therapies that these virus these viral
vectors can support
so early in the talk i mentioned these
22 that already been
approved worldwide that use
virus and so
if you think about diseases where the
treatment is
some introduction of a gene or a
correction of a gene
how do you how do you introduce that
gene that corrective gene
well the way that is safe and effective
that we're finding is
using these viral vectors so they are
being used
now already and will be used
increasingly over the years
and so what do you hope to accomplish
with that it's basically
the treatment of these diseases that
otherwise have no other treatments or
cures
and in some cases these viral vectors
can correct permanently the disease
and rather than being a treatment it can
actually be a cure so
accomplishing just increased
human health and happiness i guess is
how these studies ultimately will
help the world
sandy singh thank you so much for your
time today and for your important
research
we really appreciate it before we go i
also want to thank our audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting question
and i'd also like to thank our sponsor
mir us for sponsoring today's
webinar questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided the time of registration
and this webcast by the way can be
viewed on demand for two years till
april of
2023 labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time stay safe and stay
healthy everyone take care bye